[Musique]
j'ai l'envié de cédric 6 heures il va
remettre les lauriers comme chaque soir
c'est le cousin de franck gastambide
c'est vrai à la lie à de la celle ci
âgée surveillants franck t'inquiète pas
celui-là je serre la vis je sers la
ouazana ce besoin qui si le chef dans le
jeu que juste on a envie de savoir malik
et moi qui ai le chef dans le couple
autres franck et vous à sa sélection
navy on le sait le oui les pois c'est
quoi votre autant que pour la famille
c'est toujours la cheville oui oui toi
ça va poser une question à sabrina
savait très simple fait de quelle
origine sabrina algérienne voilà ta la
réponse est oui alors je suis très ému
de venir remettre les lauriers à la
crème de la crème de la tva française
évidemment quand je dis la crème de la
crème flopée de parler de celui qui a
réinventé la télévision le 1er avril
2010 sur france 4
allez touche pas à mon poste à ce moment
ci rennes 6 6 2 5 au lycée vous je crois
c'est comment donc vous aimez le celi
non c'est vous c'est vous c'est vous
parce que vous aimez connu oui j'aime le
comique de rythme mais aussi dans le
comique de répétition encore prouvé la
semaine dernière à propos d'une certaine
mimie mathy a dit que j'adore alors je
vous remets le laurier d'animateurs qui
pourrait faire la même veine afin d'en
discuter mardi
mais souvenez-vous du 31 mai 2000 sajoo
pas tomber
c'est la bonne préféré souvenez vous du
23 mai 2017 quelle est la peine qu'un
mini matignon n'a pas l'âge il encore du
5 mars 2018
[Applaudissements]
comme par hasard il vient nous voir si
halo alors il ya quelques jours mathieu
delormeau nous a tous émus rappelez vous
aurez c'est vrai un témoignage maculé
que vous rencontrez en ce moment et on
est en vous soutient bien sûr vous était
très ému il ya une chose que personne
n'a enlevé c'est que sans vouloir vous
avez mis une petite cartouche à cyril
bien sûr évidemment matthieu delormeau
reçoit donc le laurier du chroniqueur
qui tacle son patron sans que personne
ne s'en aperçoive
la banda les cas est en revanche très
très présente
gilles également aussi bord isabelle qui
m'aurait texto hier donc ça en revanche
les imbéciles qui disent que la télé
c'est que de la télé dont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allik argentin avoue celui qui avait le
mot le plus gentil évidemment sans le
dire est que ça c'est malik bentalha le
100 m c'est vrai oui c'est vrai les
mêmes à lui faire l'amour
ben je vous en remercie et c'est vrai
merci à cerner mais c'était toujours le
mangerait pour le vengerait hibou il est
beau dégradé progressif cameroun
cameroun alors matthieu delormeau à deux
spécialités
on se regardait toute la journée dans le
miroir de donner une info un conseil sur
n'importe quel sujet il fait ça depuis
son arrivée dans l'émission c'est vrai
et je décerne à matthieu delormeau le
laurier du chroniqueur qui essaient
toujours de donner des infos dont tout
le monde se fout que je vous donne quand
j'ai scellé chez les gens c'est ce truc
est très connue alors écoutez chéri dans
le frigidaire un ou deux tubes de
chantilly c'est que la personne qui est
propriétaire de l'appartement garçons
aux filles une grosse [ __ ] et
connard la mer en la laddh
les végétariens sont des mauvais coups
qui en tout cas c'est comme qui danse
bien bien on le sait tout ça la vraie
vraie pause pour l'eau toilettes c'est
d'être totalement accroupi et la plus
mauvaise ce sont les toilettes européen
sur lequel on est assis parce que du
coup on tord l'intestin au dos quand on
pousse et ont créé des hémorroïdes
il faut donc relever un petit peu les
jambes et se pencher en avant on
retrouve cette position franchement je
reconnais franchement j'ai essayé et
alors c'est une ligne droite
[Musique]
bébé alors chaque matin cyril vous savez
que je me lève très tôt bosser la
chronique dieu c'est bien sûr mais
surtout pour regarder l'interview
politique de jean pierre elkabbach
voilà j'adore ce mec ça fait 40 ans
qu'il en gueule tous les politiciens
personne ne lui répond ouais il m'avait
posé une question quand je sais nous
donne de quoi je me mêle les produits je
me mets comme tous les français de ce
qui nous regarde c'est pas toi ça je
sais pas s'il est heureux de recevoir
ses invités à 7 heures du matin mais là
une manière particulière de dire bonjour
à ses invités qui sortent à peine du lit
quoi et dont je décerne à jean pierre
elkabbach le laurier du journaliste le
plus accueillant de la télévision
française
j'adore du conteneur bonjour bonjour
jean pierre elkabbach ce matin je vous
laisserai pas sortir vivant de ses news
elles sortent veut bonjour bonjour si
vous continuez comme cerveau pensez pas
que vous allez finir bientôt tout nu lui
stéphane les stanislas stanislas guérini
bonjour les violences et les désordres
s'aggrave de samedi en samedi jusqu'à
quand et jusqu'à quand alors souvenez
vous quand jean pierre elkabbach avait
reçu le futur président du pakistan
elle est là nous là bonjour merci
bonjour de quoi je me mêle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a dû recevoir un texto lui et textos
pas assez longue tu dois plus loin alors
benjamin est ce qu'on vous a déjà
proposé de participer aux amours n'ont
pas encore là il va ramener tout ce
qu'on sait faire une spéciale on
mettrait bien avec toutes ses ex et
enverrait laquelle il connaît le mieux
que ça sera cool et donc à midi il y
avait un coût qui s'appelait sandrine et
christie qui se sont embrouillées à
cause de la date de naissance de belle
maman sandrine et le fener très vite
vous allez voir que c'est un peu gilles
verdez en neuf dont je le remets le
laurier du couple qui va finir comme un
mariage de benjamin castaldi les sens de
votre mère non lui la première riz
septembre top 23 septembre tamer à
l'aîné alors c'est lui qui se souvient
pas de la date de naissance de sa mère
c'est lui qui sait pas que 23 septembre
c'est de temps mais c'est sûr on a
quinze jours d'écart
donc je sais c'est sûr mais tu es né en
octobre chez ma mère
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
23 septembre ça vous dit rien vous aussi
ma maman et vous quel est le vôtre
elle prend quand elle prend un accent du
sud et celle au droit sur elle c'est son
anniversaire à votre maman et mon père
le 22 vapo perlman de merci donc le 14
moi j'ai un pote au 6 février
voilà merci alors pour finir je vous
montrer une image incroyable et vraiment
je vous assure que ce n'est pas truquée
je suis tombé sur l'émission les
déjeuners de berck of books sur sud
radio
il y avait michel boujenah comme invité
le problème quand on mange et qu'on
parle en même temps c'est qu'on peut
avoir des remontées gastriques
oui oui on peut voir remonter gacé et
michel boujenah quand il sent que ça
monte
il a une super technique pour essayer de
cacher le fait que ça va sortir
surveiller la tête de noriko macias qui
est aussi présent et vraiment je vous
jure vraiment yao kan sont ajoutés c'est
pas truqué c'est incroyable ouais il est
tellement détendu michel boujenah qui
remporte le laurier du gars qui fait
semblant de tous et pour pas qu'on voit
qu'il roth
emilie sur sud radio tout de suite
effective et jacques pc je vais vous
parler de l'actualité des deux magots
oui effectivement l'actualité en mars
aux deux magots deux événements à ne pas
rater ici ça monte michel mais la main
devant la bouche de magot oui
effectivement
deux événements ne pas rater si c'est la
teneur et colza débute mardi 10 mai à un
arrêt cardiaque ont été séparés des
bears srx
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]